[Music]
Ray Allen has been all about the threes
in his basketball career recently he was
introduced to a totally different kind
of three the Polaris slingshot
three-wheeled open-air roadster and
players has donated a vehicle to Ray
Allen's ray of hope foundation where he
will auction it off donate all the
proceeds to support education and help
build computer labs in public schools
and the great Ray Allen joins us on the
program ray ray how are you this morning
I'm good Danny how are you I'm doing
okay I saw the video the other day
you're you're in shape like you're in
shape like you were when you first came
into the league and right you put out
that video now why did you put out that
video well i was actually shooting a
small o commercial for like this segment
on the three-point shot the history of
it you know you know one of my buddies
on the sideline he just took us a slo-mo
video of it I said you know what this
this folks is because the one thing that
I get from my followers all time is that
like I never post pictures of when I'm
on the court and the reason being is
that I always feel like I'm working when
I go on the court and I never carry my
phone with me like I see these kids
these days with their phone on them
while they're playing basketball lights
are you trying to get better are you
trying to tweet like you know so I
thought that was I want to put it out
there Sophie with that no matter you
know what my age is I could Stephanie
still shoot oh that's true now freshman
year sweet 16 sophomore year Elite Eight
at Connecticut and then sweet 16 year
junior year what do you rip what's your
one memory though biggest memory of the
n-c-double-a tournament ah I think just
to be able to travel by the way we did I
believe it's in c ee tournament and you
put us in so many different places so
many different sites and you know we
were you know out west this seemed like
forever my son my junior year and you
know it felt like for the first time
being a professional athlete because we
weren't really going to classes even
though we were doing we had our studies
with us on the road just to be able to
be
as a group as a unit for as long as we
were those are some of my best memories
because we were playing basketball day
in and day out we had bench Carter on
yesterday he's 40 ranked no Duncan
hitting threes says he's gonna play
again next year that doesn't tempt you
does it tipped me yum not only does it
doesn't tip me I mean I i play on the
weekends you know it over down in my
neighborhood and you know you you get
opportunity to kind of run up and down
and and do some of the things that
you're doing or not you know I was in
Barcelona this past weekend for all-star
camp for kids Europeans kids and I'm
shooting threes with the kids they're
like how come you are not still pending
in VA like a kid you know they're trying
to figure it out and I was like well I
mean it was all about finding the right
situation and you never know from the
outside in and you know it's tough you
know at my age now you know it's not
that I couldn't do it it's about the
recovery of how my body will respond to
it Larry Bird said that in 6th Grade II
got the green light Steph Curry said his
freshman year in college he got the
green light to shoot whenever he wanted
to when did Ray Allen get the green
light um I got the green light probably
maybe I would say like my fourth year in
the NBA that one yeah it took me that it
took me that long to gain his trust I
think when I came into the NBF still
trying to figure out you know what it
was that I was going to be in this
league and I think once George Karl came
we started playing a brand of basketball
where we we were more small ball and we
took the first shot available and we did
a lot of shooting you know through our
practice you know a lot of challenge
competitions and so I got to the point
where you know I knew I was so confident
in my shooting ability and I started
learning really how to work at it so I
believe the coaches that really trusted
my abilities to be able to shoot the
ball would you feel more confident
hypothetically in the Cleveland offense
or Golden State offense
um hypothetically I i would say i would
say in the Cleveland system because
obviously i know the brown really well
and he's an incredible password and you
know just the way they they play they
play fast and similar to what Golden
State's doing but don't they have so
many shoes and you know typically the
balls gonna probably find the same group
of guys over on the course of a couple
of sessions where would you rank LeBron
among the best passers of all time you
face I would say he best passers I would
say that I played again yeah maybe he's
certainly in the top ten I'll start
there but you know there's some
incredible point guards that i played
against and i'd had to say them the ones
i fighting is my number one is you know
[Music]
I was kind of neck and neck between
Jason Kidd and John Stockton's John
Stockton was so consistent and he was
just everyday and you know he did
everything you know he was simply great
Jay kid just made some incredible passes
you know he had flair to him he always
ran the floor and he was so selfish so i
would have to give their kids a slight
nod i know that your own short on time
here if you want to give a plug to a ray
of hope foundation there will certainly
give you the time to do that well i mean
i'm just i think over the course of our
microwaves been able to have the
opportunity to give back and you know to
polaris the slingshot to be able to take
this off the vehicle know you talked
about at the top of the show to be able
to donate this this vehicle to my
foundation so we can raise money so we
can build computer labs and then
essentially done tired of human Boston
Hartford in next in Miami so you know we
really want to find a way to help the
technology it in the school for kids can
have a fighting chance as they go to
high school and step up their reading so
they can have a chance on a global scale
compete against other kids around the
world ray it's always great to talk to
you
here enjoying retirement keep it the
jumpers and thanks for joining us thank
you dan thanks Rob all right that's ray
allen the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience